- [Mark] Velanta, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I was born in Lynwood, California,
St. Francis Hospital.
- [Mark] Okay.
- [Velanta] But I grew up
in first Chicago, Illinois,
then I moved to Georgia,
which Savannah, Richmond County.
- [Mark] Chicago or Springfield.
- Springfield, Chicago, Illinois
is 1821 South Springfield.
I stayed on the street Springfield.
Went to Penn Middle School.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- Yeah, and then after that,
I moved to Atlanta, Georgia.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
Did you grow up with both your parents?
- No. I didn't, but I didn't know them.
But I ended up in a foster
home at eight months old
with lady I grew up for,
till I was 17 years old.
But my mom was a crack head,
my dad, I never really did know him,
but when I did find out,
he was a real good man.
- [Mark] Your mom was a crack head?
- Yes, my mom was a very high smoker and
I smoke now, but I really started smoking
because that's the reason why I smoke
is because my mom wouldn't deal with me
unless I smoked crack
and that's the only communication we had.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood.
- Worst times of my life,
especially when I was five years old,
it was real bad.
I went to finding out that I had a brother
that I didn't know about was.
I'd sleep out the bed every single night
where I'd get raped every
night, every night, every night.
- [Mark] By who?
- By my brother, which
was a foster brother,
which I never known, I
thought was a real brother.
- [Mark] At five years old?
- Five years old.
I used to remember everything.
I remember everything
since I was five years old.
And my mom used to literally make me sleep
by his bed while he performs his duties
every single night.
And as I got older, it tripped me out,
but the more I was
younger, it was the worst
because my mom, she was like one
of the worst moms ever, but all my life
I wanted to know who she was,
but when I got older I
didn't wanna find out.
I wanted to find out who she was,
but I didn't wanna find out who she was
due to the fact what I went through,
which at ages eight months old,
that's the last time I remember,
I found out that I saw her.
But she used to sell me and my brothers
and them to truck drivers.
It was six boys, six girls.
Besides my older sisters,
I was one of the ones she didn't like.
So I was like tortured
She tortured me regardless.
But when I turned like five years old,
I used to see my mom when she used
to take me and my brothers and them
to this building where,
they call it Lot Lizards,
where the truck drivers go
where they sell prostitutes.
She used to sell my
little brothers and them,
go to the truck and they used to go
and I used to just stand there like...
And then one day I did that
and I was one of the ones in the row.
I usually didn't be that.
But I guess as time went on,
she had her favorites.
I wasn't one of her favorites,
so she used to send me to the...
And I used to remember
the truck drivers used
to touch on on me and fondle with me
and fondle with me and play.
I used to cry, but I got used to it.
- [Mark] What age?
- I was like going, I was
around about five years old.
That's when I first really start knowing
what sex was, five years old.
- [Mark] How long did this go on?
- Till I was seven.
- [Mark] What city was this?
- This was in...
Yeah, the truck drivers,
it was in Atlanta, like Savannah,
like Richmond County, like
somewhere up in there.
It was South Park where
nobody could like...
You would never think
you could ever know stuff
going like that, so yeah.
- [Mark] So your mom was
doing this for money for?
- For money for drugs.
- [Mark] For crack.
- Yeah. Drugs, drugs.
Had to pay off drug dealers that she owed.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- From five till I was seven,
then seven to 11.
Now this at the time was my brother
where I end up having a baby with him
when I turned 17.
She used to make me sleep
by the bed every night.
After the truck driving stuff,
that's when the brother came in
and every single night
she used to make me sleep
by his bed till I was seven.
Seven on down till I was 11.
Then it was 11 till I was 13
and then one day I told her
when I turned like 15, 16.
I was like, "Yeah, your son is,
when you leave, he's molesting me."
But he used to call on
the telephone all the time
from the Army like,
"Yeah, yeah, can I speak
to my sister," and I used to be like,
"No, I don't wanna talk to him."
She'd still make me get on the phone.
So when I told her around about 11 to 13,
yeah, when I was 13,
I told her what happened.
She wouldn't believe me.
I was like, "Yeah, your son," woo, woo.
She was like, "No, what did he do?"
She knew already, you
know what I'm saying?
She just wanted to see if I remember it.
So I went to school
with this little bitty shirt.
She whooped the whoo,
whooped me, like beat me.
I went to school with a belly shirt on,
some little bitty shorts
when I went to school
and I sat down in the classroom
and the teacher was like,
"Miss Babbitt, are you okay?"
I'm like, I didn't say anything.
She seen on the whips on my arm.
She took me outside,
she asked me what's going on.
And I said, "My mama
whipped me," woo, woo.
I just came back in the classroom,
I sat down.
I'd say five minutes later the police came
and social services.
Went to the lady house,
told her that she
couldn't have me no more.
That's when I found out
she wasn't my real mom.
But all along I was thinking she's my mom
because I was so little.
So I'm thinking it was my mom,
but it wasn't.
And when I told her that at 16,
she knew what she was doing,
but I didn't know.
But then she was like she
didn't wanna be my mom no more.
And then I end up going to a foster home
where my dad, he died.
He always said, "Before I die,
I want you to know who your sisters are."
He found them.
He died and I find my sister
and I found out I was pregnant.
- [Mark] With your brother?
- With my brother's child.
- [Mark] Your biological brother.
- No, this is the brother-
- [Mark] Foster brother.
- From eight months on
down to 16 years old
until I told her what her son was doing
and then wham.
But my mom knew the lady, though.
The lady practically
took me from her, my mom,
because they both was like drug dealers,
like they both smoked together.
But my mama didn't know
that the lady was gonna switch on her.
She liked me so much that
she took me from her.
So her and my mom went to court for me
and then end up, choo,
she ended up getting me
and I met my mom when
I turned 18, well 17,
when my dad died.
And she's still the same way.
But now she got killed by
the Grand Sleeper, though.
- [Mark] She what?
- She got killed by the Grand Sleeper.
- [Mark] The?
- The guy after the Grim Reaper.
- [Mark] Yeah, the guy
here in this neighborhood.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So your mom
was in this neighborhood
for a while?
- My mom used to stay right there
on Wall and Broadway.
- [Mark] So she was one of his victims?
- Yeah, she was the last one.
- [Mark] Wow.
So you guys were both living here
on the streets together.
- No, my mom had her own spot.
I used to have my own spot, too,
and I used to stay at Prince and stuff,
but I was back and forth in the streets
because I really wanted to know her,
but she really didn't wanna know me.
Unless I had crack, she
didn't wanna see me.
- [Mark] How many years
you been down here?
- [Velanta] I been down here two years,
but six months
I only been outside.
And since I been out here,
I done got sodomized, I got raped,
I kidnapped with my eight-month old son,
which the guy stays
right here on the corner.
I don't know if you know
the big girl, Keisha.
She have a brother named Jamie.
Well, yeah, him.
He gave me something,
it's called trap dope,
where I was doing crystal for 12 years.
When I got with the guy,
he was doing crystal
and where they put
heroin inside the crystal
and it's called trap dope.
So come to find out, I was trapped
in they house for like eight days up,
me and my son, eight months old.
And the last day was they found out
I had a lawsuit with my
son that died before him
in California Hospital.
Yeah, they found a lawsuit paper
when I was at the hospital
from having a seizure
and so what they started doing,
they started giving me
stuff to trap me there
to where they could get enough time
to go through the paperwork,
find out what was going on,
disguise theyself as me
and get me and my son.
But me being the strong person that I am,
I broke through that.
So, I broke through
that is when the bottle
came out with crystal.
You know you give a baby sugar water.
It was crystal water.
My baby wouldn't wake up,
but I was up for seven days.
And I'm like wow, my son he
wasn't moving, wasn't moving.
How I got away is they always up so long
trying to kidnap me and
my son to get the money,
they end up falling asleep
and Lord have mercy, I
called the ambulance.
I even got their mom out,
'cause they was chastising her, too.
But come to find out that
was all over some lawsuit.
- [Mark] How many kids do you have?
- I have 10, I have five
boys, I have five girls.
- - [Mark] And-
- My oldest is 19 and he's
doing 90 years for murder.
My second son, two of my kids,
they're in Utah because me
and their dad got into it.
I left my husband of 17 years.
2016, I left him in
Vegas, I came down here.
He didn't have no benefits.
I gave him two of his sons,
which is the same name as
him, Demetrice and Demetrius.
They went to Utah where he was dealing
with a girl out here that we used
to buy crystal from and they
ended up moving to Utah.
- [Mark] Did I hear that right,
you named your son Demetrice-
- Demetrice and Demetrious.
It's I-O-U-S and I-C-E.
Antoine, Antoine one is junior
and one is the third, yeah.
And my oldest is
Montavious Daytron Babbitt.
Yeah.
And I have, Darion Charles Brewer
and D'Angelo Saquan Brewer.
My daughters, five, Antonasia,
Anastasia, Kuwai,
Stephanie and Paris, yeah.
So five boys, five girls.
- [Mark] Did you raise any of your kids?
- I raised six of my kids, six.
Before the dad, I gave the dad two
after I left in 2016,
so he could take care
of two of his boys.
End up going with a crystal meth head lady
and they moved to Texas.
Out there, the girl end up stabbing him.
He went to jail.
They put my two boys that
I gave him for benefits in,
they stayed hotel, but they put him in a,
what you call it, a shelter.
Well, he went to jail, he got out.
When he got out, he came to
the place crystal methed out.
And they took the boys from him,
so now my boys are divided in two,
which I talk to them every single day.
One of them I can't get in touch with,
but the other one I talk to every day.
That's the Demetrice and Demetrious
and they are some beasts,
they're just like their mom.
But they have no feelings because all
they did was get beat.
Like my oldest son, the
baby daddy I was with
he shot my little son with a BB gun.
One of the Demetrious, he hit him
in the eye with a belt buckle
because he wouldn't go to sleep
and he choked out my
eight-month-old daughter,
which became Down's Syndrome because
she wouldn't stop crying.
And I was working at
Labor Ready in Las Vegas
when that happened.
So, you know what I'm saying,
I was like, I didn't whip my kids,
so I was a threat to my
kids because they felt like
I was putting them in danger
with family members,
when I was really working
and doing what I supposed to do,
but others was on other
type of chemical drugs
to where I couldn't
perform my duties as a mom.
You know what I'm saying?
I used to couldn't send them to school
with raggedy shoes on, people look at 'em.
I used to spend $1,200 every single month,
pregnant, on a bicycle
to pay rent for them
when I stayed in Bakersfield, Georgia.
I did everything on my own until now.
I'm still trying to do
everything on my own,
but it's deceiving, but life is very hard
because now I'm going through a situation
with my daughter.
Her name is Stephanie McKee Brewer.
She was kidnapped March 23rd
and her birthday was March 24th.
She came out here to find me.
They never found her.
They had an APB out.
Everybody knew about it.
She knew where I was,
but they never stayed there to find her.
She's still gone right now.
- [Mark] You ever talk to her?
- No.
But now it's a situation I'm going through
where now every night I hear the screams,
like, "Mom, mom, mom, mom, mom, help me,"
and it's driving me crazy
'cause I been hearing it
for the last six months.
And it's not a game.
- [Mark] How old is she?
- My daughter? She's 15 years old.
- [Mark] 15.
- 15.
She look just like me.
Yep.
And she's out here somewhere
and a lot of people know.
That's they way of
feeling that they got me.
You know what I'm saying?
But I won't let it out,
you know what I'm saying?
You have to get evidence
in order to, you can't just go out there
and say oh, she's in the
room, she's here, she's here
and then they get there
and they think you crazy
and send you to the crazy house.
No, I have to be strong for her.
But she still, it's been
six months, seven months.
And she's out here somewhere close
and everybody knows it.
But you know what I'm saying,
I gotta be strong.
That's why I'm trying to get my place
and start everything
I'm supposed to do, SSI.
I'm going to sober living on Monday.
You know what I'm saying?
It's all for my kids and I'm glad
I could speak this because right now
I'm not too emotional
because I used the drug
as a numbness and it's
not, I didn't use any,
so it's not making no emotions come
as I would when I didn't
talk the last time.
- [Mark] This is our fourth
time of trying this, right?
- [Velanta] Yes, and I think
I'm doing great this time.
- [Mark] You're doing great.
You're doing absolutely great this time
because the other three
were kind of unusable.
- [Velanta] No, not today. I'm sober.
- [Mark] This one I'll use.
All right, Velanta, thanks
so much for talking to me.
- No problem.
- [Mark] Good luck with your adventures.
- Yes.
I did it.
- [Mark] We did it.